[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
Red Dead Redemption 2 is within touching
distance and like most rockstar fans
I've read every single morsel of
information I can from those people
lucky enough to have played the game
already here are 28 things I believe you
need to know about Red Dead Redemption 2
or 1 if you've still got GTA 5 get it
reinstalled right now there's some free
content to unlock for redemption 2 but
we'll get to that very soon by now I
think we all know the basic setting of
the game but just in case I'll quickly
reiterate Red Dead Redemption 2 is set
before the actions of the first game
twelve years in fact and 19 years after
Red Dead Revolver I have a breakdown of
both those stories coming next week by
the way we play as Arthur Morgan the
second-in-command of the dutch van der
Linde band of outlaws at the turn of the
century the cowboy way of life was under
threat and as we join the game we play
through the final years of this
seemingly villainous gang as this is a
sequel returning characters are pivotal
we've already seen John Marston and we
know that he is an NPC in the game but
so too are his son Jack and wife Abigail
others that can be noticed include uncle
and of course all the gang Dutch Xavier
bill this has got me thinking about
other characters we could see from other
Red Dead games maybe London Ricketts the
greatest gunslinger in the West this
time setting would have been the peak of
his skill sets so hopefully he'll pop up
there's a plethora of characters who
could return and I think will reappear
in Red Dead Redemption to in fact come
back to the channel next week for a
breakdown of the most likely cameos
we'll see
the outlaw camp that we stay in will act
as the main hub of the game for missions
and interactions the camp will require
upkeep to improve the morale of the
group
Arthur is able to contribute such as
helping others with their issues are
simply hunting for food ultimately we
need those happy campers when going on
missions with our gang mates keep in
mind that Arthur can loot bodies like it
expect but here's the potential issue
your gang companions will do the same
yeah they'll loot everyone time to move
quickly Arthur just in case you're
worried that you don't remember Red Dead
Redemption won or dislikes those
characters worried no longer there are
new characters to meet and the entire
story although full of nods to the
original games will never expect you to
have played them the story is completely
unique just like in GTA 5 it is possible
to play Red Dead Redemption - in first
person are the typical third-person
perspectives the animations have been
improved so first person should be less
nauseating this time around if you're a
Fallout player the ability to switch
views will be appreciated but for me I'm
sticking with third person out of
interest will you play in first-person
perspective we've been told this is a
living breathing world but come on we
hear that about every single game that's
ever released but in Red Dead Redemption
to something as inconsequential as the
wildlife in the trees has been expanded
upon almost 200 species of wildlife can
be found when we're not there they'll
live their own way with predators and
prey the food chain in full flow of
course we can disrupt that ecosystem and
no mankind will hunt them all to
extinction or something I found
interesting if after shoots say a deer
too many times its carcass will be
ruined and the pelt it won't be worth a
penny one bullet right between the eyes
is what's required here to help us out
Dead Eye from Red Dead Redemption and
revolver is back again and levels up
throughout the game in its basic form
Dead Eye will slow down time like the
matrix with upgrades we'll begin to
paint targets and unleash a barrage of
metal to their skulls it's even possible
to find weak spots on each enemy Wow who
knew that ahead was a weak spots nice
hey as we're already talking about
weapons let's dig a little bit deeper
Rockstar are trying to be a little bit
more realistic in Red Dead Redemption to
remember the gta5 weapon wheel where
you'd be able to pull a minigun out of
your backside no such look in Redemption
- Arthur is only able to carry two
sidearms at once or two rifles at once
other things like knives can be carried
- as long as it fits in with the
character and the world the weapons
themselves will degrade over time just
like in Red Dead Revolver the damage
output will be affected all the time to
reload will increase or the accuracy
will reduce these stats are impacted
upon by real-world interactions small
things like walking through a river
cause your favorite weapon to rust and
degrade don't worry we can repair them
but knowing this issue may drive us to
find a bridge rather than risking
crossing a river on foot going back to
the hunting point again if a pelt is
placed on your horse and walks through a
river it's likely to fall off and become
waterlogged and useless so tiny things
just like that have an impact on your
overall experience and if that carcass
is left too long it will decompose
attracting vultures and coyotes I am
those coyotes one last note about
weapons it's possible to blow enemy
limbs off with shotguns
how lovely does that sound the honor
system found in many games is once again
in Red Dead Redemption too generally
it's a choice of good or bad but
hopefully it will have more depth than
that your actions have consequences and
reflects in the way you are treated in
the world and even the killcams will be
different if you're a trusted worthy
gentleman Arthur your kill cam will
focus on you looking damn good whereas
if you're an evil sob the camera will
focus on the holes you put in people I
don't know about you but I'm going to be
a complete horrible little but usually
in video games the gameplay uncooked
scenes are easily noticed in Red Dead
Redemption to Rockstar are attempting to
raise standards and combine gameplay and
cinematic seamlessly look at this
example as Arthur takes the shot it
cooks into the dialogue instantly
maintaining the flow between shots this
is raising the bar completely speaking
of killing people
the wanded mechanic returns again like
in the previous Red Dead should you
commit a crime you will become a wanted
man this will be broken down into stages
of severity depending on witnesses
Arthur could remain unknown a sheriff or
bounty hunter may arrive but they don't
know what Arthur looks like so our
anonymity is intact as long as we can
blend in on the other end of the scale
it's the good old wanted dead or alive
like you'd guess they'll be gunning for
you knowing exactly what you look like
and chances are they prefer to kill you
than take you alive there are small ways
to help yourself such as using a bandana
to cover your face during crime capers
even paying off bounties is possible but
wand the NPCs will remember and
potentially bring it up later in the
story kind of like zelda and stealing
something from a store only to return
ten hours later and find the store owner
still wants to murder you have you ever
played The Witcher 3 cost you bloody
well have well just like Geralt Arthur's
hair will grow over time and so will his
facial hair it's your choice if you let
him resemble a hippie or you go for the
clean-cut route personally I'm making
Arthur into a Viking I do hope we can
shape his beard in addition to hair
growth clothing hunger cleanliness
weather changes are all present and
affect one another as the cold weather
closes in Arthur will require changes to
his attire something as simple as a coat
on top of his usual clothing will help
without that extra layer stamina will
deplete quicker
similarly with food Arthur can and must
chow down just like in real life was
cheesecake a thing back then I hope it
was of course eating too much will cause
Arthur to pile on the pounds so I'm
going to make a bearded blob of a cowboy
just like Hagrid you're a cowboy hurry
maps eyes and locations have been
revealed and like it expect the map is
touted to be the largest ever
realistically though the map will feel
larger due to the modes of transport
from back in the time try as it might
that horse can't travel as fast as an
aeroplane in gta5 in terms of specific
locations Red Dead Redemption 2 has five
areas confirmed at present New Hanover
New Austin West Elizabeth amber Eno and
Lemoine sorry about the pronunciation
there new Austin and West Elizabeth both
appeared in the previous Red Dead game
which means armadillo fought Mercer and
the McFarland Ranch should hopefully
still be around remember the first time
John went to Fort Mercer in Red Dead as
an added unsubstantiated point here
recently it has been suggested that the
entire Red Dead Redemption 1 map will be
playable in Red Dead Redemption - could
this mean we see the original game
released as DLC I'm likely overreaching
they're back to locations but to be a
little bit more specific inside
locations all these places will have
buildings to enter there'll be a ton of
interiors to discover in Red Dead
Redemption - and for me the greatest
thing here are those drawers and
cupboards to be opened for
I know this sounds really underwhelming
but I love Easter eggs and we'll be
scavenging through every single draw to
find out what happened to red Harlow at
the end of Red Dead Revolver here's a
point to note about locations in general
as we complete each story mission time
will pass in the game sometimes a few
minutes sometimes a few days sometimes
even longer
this means the settlements you're in
will change evolve grow deplete a newly
created building will be a little bit
tall the next time you see it or maybe a
bank heist involves blowing up a wall
that wall will need to be rebuilt over
time in the game if you play fortnight
think of it like that building and
tilted towers that took months to
rebuild in Red Dead Redemption 2 the
complete map will evolve over time and
will likely end looking like that
of Red Dead Redemption one every single
Rockstar game comes with improvements to
artificial intelligence Red Dead 2 will
have a space off with enemies who will
flank us they'll hide they'll sneak into
different vantage points they'll climb
above us to gain the high ground
advantage our dr2 should see the
greatest AI we've faced in a rockstar
game to be honest I'm gonna miss Red
Dead Revolver Zay I I loved those
buffoons
so I mentioned GTA 5 at the start of the
video most people have two copies of
that game since it released over to
console generations you may not be aware
but two weapons for Red Dead Redemption
2 can be unlocked right now inside GTA 5
literally free unlocks for playing grand
theft auto to grab the new weapons login
to GTA online and follow bounty hunter
missions which come through your phone
from mod taking down a few bounties will
reward you with the stone hatchet both
in GTA online and Red Dead Redemption
2 there's also a treasure hunt to
complete which again rewards you with a
weapon in both games this time is the
double action revolver that's a pretty
damn good touch from Rockstar and
remember when we made our characters in
GTA online we could be the
great-great-great
great-great-great-great grandson of John
Marston himself speaking of GTA are
worried many players have is how horses
will replace their beloved vehicles
while put bluntly they're the same they
have stats they have paint jobs they
have alloys they have wheel trims but ok
they don't have those but to a degree
they are customizable but the main focus
will
to build up a bond with your horse
feeding them calming them down caring
for them but if that doesn't sound
masculine and manly enough for you we
can instead find rare breeds of horses
in Red Dead 2 which have improved stats
if you remember all those years ago in
the DLC for Red Dead 1 we could locate
the four horses of the Apocalypse
literally horse is taking the fabled
titles of famine pestilence war and
death expect Red Dead online to have a
range of horses to find oh that's
another segue Red Dead online the online
portion of Rockstar Games has become
huge business bloody shark cards expect
Red Dead 2 to attempt to claim our very
souls for about 5 years just like GTA 5
did around late November the Red Dead
online beta will begin the beta part is
very important here
remember the issues with GTA online when
it first released expect something
similar with Red Dead but once this
smooths out probably by January then
expect content to be added regularly to
allow you and friends to rob banks take
down rival gangs and generally cause
havoc everywhere let's get back to the
main campaign though and things that we
know side quests will be another
important element in Red Dead 2 with the
main story impacted by seemingly
unrelated side missions not only that
but one of the greatest things in the
original game was the strangers and free
Commission's such as helping a chap who
is convinced he could fly he most
definitely couldn't all there was a
woman looking for her husband who I'm
pretty sure was a ghost
these missions were insane and packed
full of character more of that in RDR 2
will be fantastic in addition to being a
badass cowboy they'll be pastimes to
allow you to chill out from time to time
how about a game of poker or a nice
bloodbath game of five finger fillet or
if that's not to your speed what about
fishing the world is built to immerse
you you don't have to go into any
missions if you just want to relax a
small but highly impactful piece of
information is about your heads-up
display
Red Dead Redemption 2 gives us a fully
customizable Hut if you ever played God
of War without all the on-screen clutter
you know how immersive that can feel
from the outset Red Dead Redemption 2
has a reduced hood but it can be tweaked
further to make the game feel more film
like we can shut it off completely - it
may make the game a little bit more
difficult
but it'll look damn impressive and
finally as if you didn't already know
Red Dead Redemption to releases on
October the 26th it's so close over the
next few weeks I'll be breaking down the
stories of reddit Redemption and Red
Dead Revolver and looking at characters
we will likely see again I'm currently
replaying Red Dead Redemption right now
to find pieces of information that
should apply to Red Dead - such as did
you know John had a daughter more on
that next week I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade spin the bloody pleasure I'll
see you next time
[Music]